oh my god
oh my gosh greatest movie of all time
oh my gosh
spiderman nelly home is the greatest
superhero movie of all time greatest
superhero movie
of all time
of all time
i cried so much i cried so much
oh my gosh guys i can't even tell you oh
my god
[Music]
oh my god
what is up everybody we just got out of
the world premiere for spider-man
no way home
and i'm blown away
the greatest superhero movie
of all time
of all time it beats avengers in game
infinity war it's amazing i i don't even
like no spoilers in this video no
spoilers i just but like whatever you
think
about the movie you don't know you just
don't know our expectations actually
weren't high they weren't high enough
in in ways you didn't think about in
ways you didn't think about
like i cried so much in the movie i
cried so much there's so many emotions
again no spoilers so we're not diving
into details but it is the greatest
movie
that i that i think i've seen there's
too much to process it's a lot to
process and i need more time we're
literally outside in the rain right now
right here
it's it's insane deer's right here we
had to walk away because it's very very
that's brandon davis of confidence
but i mean
mind-blowing mind-blowing mind blown in
ways that you weren't in ways that
you're not expecting like seriously if
you followed me
in ways you aren't expecting some things
aren't what they seem and i'm okay with
that
i'm super okay with that get to the
theater as soon as possible soon as you
can go watch this movie please as soon
as you can go watch this movie because
it is honestly amazing it is the best
movie
in my personal opinion
it's the greatest superhero movie of all
time so far
it's the best comic book movie like
whatever you want to call it it's my
favorite movie all the time right now
and i just i put my mind's blood my mind
is blown and that that takes a lot
it takes a lot this is a
20 out of 10 rating for the movie 20 out
of 10. it's insane so go see that as
soon
as you can
look out for our review tomorrow no
spoilers no spoiler review tomorrow
morning look out for chris's and cosmic
culture we should post them relatively
early relatively early the embargo is
already lifted we could talk about right
now but we're not going to we're going
to process our
thoughts because it's like holy crap but
um
i i don't know i don't even i don't even
my mind's blown i did i cried i laughed
i screamed we stood up so many times in
the movie and clapped like
like like just everybody in the theater
stood up and clapped and it was it was
fantastic and it was amazing and
i love you all three thousand
count fire video tomorrow woof
[Music]